hey guys it's Abby sharp here we're
gonna do a little what I eaten today
carny food edition so we're at the
credible it's kind of a summer tradition
for me and you know the carnivals kind
of like Christmas on crack it's like
your once a year trying to try as many
outrageous pizzas
the fair has to offer there's a lot of
them and you know some people call this
like the ultimate cheat day but I'm like
that
I kind of take issue with that is that
term I don't like cheat days because I
feel concept is like you allow yourself
a cheat day you're just setting yourself
up for this kind of binge restrict cycle
where the second that you get your hands
on what you've been craving all weeks
you need to dine yourself you know a
good balanced diet
you go all wild and then you restrict
and restrain and field
another reason to let next cheat day
comes along it's not good right
doesn't feel good and I don't like that
so good that you know we only go to the
carnival
to eat salad if you really come to the
carnival to experience all the fun crazy
carnival foods that it has to offer
so let's go
okay so I'm super excited about ninth
person the taste here this is a [ __ ] me
stocks it's like a donut cone filled
with frozen yogurt and some bacon bits
and maple syrup I haven't had this at
all but I'd be waiting all summer for it
so I'm really excited again
all right expert carny tips sharing
means caring honestly I don't think I
would want to eat an entire plate of
anything that I've had today actually
some of those quite gross so definitely
not but I think it's more about tasting
the kind of once per your silliness and
the carny traditions than it is about
making yourself feel uncomfortable
hey guys I've been looking for this
pulled pork and bacon spawn cinnamon bun
all day smells pretty good so we're
gonna give it a try as a tray just as it
sounds
all right so tiny Tom's Donuts is like
an institution it is a must have
tradition every single time I'm here at
the exit every single year some really
excited
so even though it is carny food day it
doesn't mean I need to completely shut
out my body's signals and needs for what
it wants and after so much deep-fried
pulled for sugar glazed foods
my body was screaming for some fruits
and vegetables so this is really the
benefit of avoiding that cheat day
mentality because it can be really easy
to miss those signs and signals from
your body when they're telling you you
know this is how I actually want to be
nourished right now and that is okay it
might be a poutine one time and it might
be a big beautiful bowl of salad greens
just own it all right guys I'm so
excited I've been literally walking
around all day trying to find this
rainbow grilled cheese thing it's not
right behind me
so I'm so happy I cannot wait to dig
into this Unicorn of a grilled cheese
sandwich let's do it
hey guys so I had an awesome day trying
it all this fun party food
I'm feeling pretty good all considering
I think I walked a lot I listen to my
body when it said no more sugar see the
play you know I have a bunch that I'm
going to be craving a nice big one
just about I don't know we'll see I
don't mean ice guys I'd love to hear
from you what are your thoughts won't
you day yay nay you know do they work
for you also what kind of scenarios do
you want to see me - for what I eat okay
so leave me a comment below give me the
thumbs up if you like this video
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen